Çeviri: Lale ilyar
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Dünya değişiyor.
Bunu suda hissediyorum.
Toprakta hissediyorum.
Kokusunu alıyorum.
Eskilerden pek bir şey kalmadı,
zira hatırlayanlardan yaşayan yok artık.
Merhaba,
Ben hikayaler anlatmaya çalışan birisiyim.
O yüzden en sevdiğim hikayelerden birinin
başlagıcıyla başlamak istedim sözlerimi.
Dünyanın değiştiğini söyleyen
ve aslında bakarsanız bir yönüyle de
dünyayı değiştiren bir hikaye.
İlginçtır,sadece içinde yaşadığımız
ve büyük bir canlı olarak
değerlendirebileceğimiz dünya değil,
aynı zamanda onun içinde yaşayan
ve küçük birer dünya olan bizler de
sürekli olarak değişiyoruz.
Ve değişirken bir yandan
onu da değiştiriyoruz.
İşte ben bütün bu değişimleri
daha iyi görebilmek için
belgeseller çekmeye çalışıyorum.
Dünya’yı ve içinde yaşayan insanları
daha iyi belgeyebilmek için.
Tarkovsky’nın deyimiyle
“Zamanı mühürlemek.”
Peki niye?
Neden avuçlarımızın arasından akıp giden
zamanı durdurmaya çalışıyoruz ki?
Onun bizi dönüştüreceği şeyden
korktuğumuz için mi,
yoksa anı yakalayabilmek için mi?
“Kopar goncaları
henüz vakit varken bugün.”
Şair niçin böyle bir dize kullanmış?
Çünkü ister inanın,
İster inanmayın,
bu salondaki herkes
bir gün nefes almayı bırakacak.
Çünkü anbean bu dünyadaki
hikayemiz sonuna yaklaşıyor.
Oysa biz?
Biz sonsuzluğu istiyoruz.
Yada en azından
içinde yaşadığımız anları yakalayıp,
ölümsüzleştirmek.
İşte ben bu yüzden
belgesel çekmeye çalışıyorum.
Bundan yaklaşık beş yıl kadar önce,
henüz daha Selfie kavramı
icat bile edilmemişken,
bir gün cep telefonumu çıkartıp
kendi fotoğrafımı çektim,
anı yakalayabilmek için.
Sonra ertesi gün aynı açıyla
bir kere daha çektim.
Daha sonra bir kere daha,
bir kere daha derken,
bunu bir projeye dönüştürdüm.
Anı yakalamak çabamın
bir göstergesi olarak.
Öte yandan geçtiğimiz günlerde,
aylarda Youtube’ta video blog
yada popüler deyimiyle
vloglar çekmeye başladım.
Ne yapıyorum, hayatımdan küçük kesitler
yakalayıp bunları saklıyorum
ve başkalarıyla paylaşıyorum.
Bütün bu çabalarıma da
kişisel belgeselcilik adını veriyorum.
Kişisel belgeselcilik.
Ama bu işi özellikle de
belgeselcilik kısmını benden
çok çok daha iyi yapanlarda var.
Mesela şu belgesele bir bakın.
Burada gördüğünüz çocuklar
hayatlarında ilk kez bir araya geliyorlar.
Hepsi de yedi yaşında, sıradan çocuklar.
Tabi kendilerine göre
farklı hayat hikayeleri var,
farklı sosyal çevrelerden geliyorlar.
Peki 1963 yılının bu soğuk kış gününde,
böyle bir hayvanat bahçesinde,
neden bir araya getirilmişler dersiniz?
Bir de ne yapmak için?
Bir belgesel çekmek için.
Gelecekte dünyanın neye dönüşeceğini
daha iyi anlayabilmek için.
Çünkü bu çocuklardan biri bugün,
yani 2016’da belki de
bir mağazada tezgahtar olarak çalışıyor.
Onun hemen yanındaki diğer bir çocuksa,
o mağazalar zincirinin
en tepesindeki yönetici, kim bilir?
Ama şu anda onları izlerken,
hepsini tertemiz, bembeyaz,
bomboş sayfalar olarak görüyoruz.
Zaman geçtikçe herkes
kendi üslubunca kendi defterini
doldurmaya başlayacak.
Ölü ozanlar derneğinde
Bay Keating’in yaptığı gibi.
Ve yaptırdığı gibi.
Geçmişe ait bu simaları
incelemenizi istiyorum.
Sizden pek farklı görünmüyorlar,
öyle değil mi?
Sizin şu anda kendizi hissettiğiniz gibi
yenilmez hissediyorlar.
Mesela şu iki afacana bakın.
İsimleri Bruce ve Neil.
Kaderlerinde çok büyük işler
başarmak olduğuna inanıyorlar,
çoğunuz gibi.
Özellikle sağ tarafta vıcır vıcır
konuşan Neil’a bir bakın.
Gözlerine,
ışık dolu, hayat dolu, umut dolu,
tıpkı sizler gibi.
Peki bu çocuklar
güçlerinin yettiği şeyleri
yapabildiler mi?
Yoksa iş işten geçene kadar
beklediler mi ?
Dünya değiştikçe
onlar neye dönüştüler acaba?
Keşke bunları görebilseydik.
Aynı temenni bu belgeselleri çekenlerin de
aklına gelmiş olmalı,
çünkü yedi yıl sonra,
1970’de, artık 14 yaşına gelmiş olan
bu 14 çocuğu tekrar ziyaret ederek,
belgeselin ikinci bölümünü çekmişler.
Bu bölümde Neil’ı bisikletiyle
okula giderken görüyoruz.
Artık o bir öğrenci.
Bu her haliden belli.
Öğrenci olması öğrenci de,
gözlerindeki ışığa ne oldu?
Yavaş yavaş sönmeye başladı.
Peki ya yedi yıl daha geçerse,
o ışık tamamen kayıp mı olacak?
İşte benim gibi,
sizler gibi meraklı belgeselciler,
bu sorunun da cevabını merak etmişler
ve 21 yaşındaki bu gençleri
tekrar ziyaret etmişler.
Şimdi yıl, 1977.
Bunu Neil’ın kıyafetinden de
anlayabilirsiniz.
O zamanın modasıyla giyinmiş.
Oxford Üniversitesi'ne başvurmuş,
ama maalesef bu başvuru kabul edilmemiş.
Başka bir üniversiteye girmiş ama
büyük ihtimalle orada da tutunamamış.
O yüzden şu anda okulsuz birisi.
Röportajda kendisine şu soru soruluyor,
"Yeniden 7 yaşında olmak ister miydin?"
Bunu biraz düşünmenizi istiyorum.
Yeniden 7 yaşında olmak ister miydin?
İster miydin?
Peki olabilseydin neyi değiştirirdin?
Peki onu şimdi niye değiştirmiyorsun?
Anı yakalamak birazda bu değil mi?
Şu andan itibaren başlamak.
Neil hayır diyor bu soruya.
“7 yaşında olmak istemezdim,Çünkü
yine 21 yaşına geleceğimi biliyorum."
Ama yine de hayatta önemli biri olmak
ve başkalarının hayatını olumlu yönde
etkilemek istiyor.
Yani değişmek ve dünyayı değiştirmek.
İşte bu Neil ve
onun 13 arkadaşının hayatına
mercek tutan belgeselin 4.bölümü,
1984 yılında yayınlanıyor.
Ve Neil artık işsiz biri
ve evsiz biri.
O yüzden otostopla İngiltere'yi dolaşarak,
kendisine kalacak bir yerler
aramaya başlıyor.
Yedi yıl boyunca,
böyle bir hayatı sürdürdükten sonra
nihayet,
İskoçya yakınlarında küçük bir adada
kendisine kalacak bir yer buluyor.
Hatta oradaki yerel tiyatroda
küçük roller almaya başlıyor.
Dünya sahnesinde oynadığı bu
hayat oyununda,
Bu kez onu gerçekten de
bir oyuncu olarak görüyoruz.
Peki acaba dönüştüğü kişiden memnun mu?
Sizce nasıl görünüyor?
Hâlâ kendisini yenilmez hissediyor mudur?
Dünyayı değiştirebileceğini
düşünüyor mudur?
Zaten ona şu soruyu soruyorlar,
“Sence başarısız mı oldun?”
Aynı soruyu kendinize sormanızı istiyorum.
Sence başarısız mı oldun?
Başarı dediğimiz şey ne peki?
Ulaşılmak istenilen bir hedef,
aranılıp bulunmak üzere olan bir hazine.
Nedir başarı?
Peki Neil’ın cevabını
merak ediyor musunuz?
“Buna ben karar veremem ki.”diyor,
“Henüz hayatım bitmedi.”
Hâlâ değişebileceğine inanan
bir insanın cevabı bu.
Nitekim 42 yaşında,
Onu çocukluk arkadaşı
Bruce’un yanında görüyoruz.
Bruce’u hatırladınız, değil mi?
Hani yedi yaşında
Neil vıcır vıcır konuşurken,
onun yanıda sessiz sakin oturan
bir çocukcağız vardı ya?
İşte o.
Aslında bakarsanız bu belgesel
yedi yıllık fasılalarla
Bruce’un hayatını da bize aktarıyor
ama onunkisi biraz daha tanıdık,
birazcık daha sıradan bir hayat biçimi.
Üniversitede alınan matematik eğitimi,
ardından mezuniyet, derken öğretmenlik,
evlilik, iki çocuk, vesaire vesaire.
Peki Neil’ın bunca yıl sonra
çocukluk arkadaşının yanında ne işi var?
Bu sorunun cevabı için hafızalarınızı
biraz tazelemenizi istiyorum.
21 yaşındaki halini düşünmenizi.
Hani üniversite’yi bırakmıştı
ama yine de
hayatta önemli biri olmak
istediğini söylemişti,
dünyayı değiştirmek istediğini.
"O zaman, peki bunu nasıl yapacaksın?"diye
sorduklarında da,
“Bilmem belki de politikaya atılırım.”
cevabını vermişti.
21 yıl boyunca bunu yapamadı,
ama 42 yaşında onu Londra’da
yerel bir mecliste konsey üyesi
olarak çalıştığını görüyoruz.
Hatta aradan bir yedi yıl daha geçiyor,
bölge meclisine terfiye ediyor.
Aradan bir yedi yıl daha geçiyor
ve 2012 yılında bu belgeselin
8.bölümü yayınlandığında karşımızda artık
İngiltere’de genel seçimlere de katılmış
liberal demokrat bir politikacı var.
Şimdi benim size belki de
bir başarı hikayesi
anlatmamı bekliyordunuz.
Yani onun seçimleri kazandığını,
hayallerine kavuştuğunu söylememi,
mutlu son.
Ama hayır.
Başaramadı, kazanamadı,
çünkü gerçek hayat hikayeleri
bilinmezliklerle doludur.
Ama güzel olanda bu değil mi zaten?
Bilinmez olması.
Zaten bu belgesel de Neil’ın hayatı
ve hayatında yaptığı yolcuklukta
henüz bitmedi daha devam ediyor.
Ve ben şu anda heyecanla,
büyük bir merakla
2019’da yayınlanacak olan
yeni bölümü bekliyorum.
Peki neden yedi yıl?
Açıkçası ben sorunun cevabını
izlediğim belgeselde bulamadım.
Ama biyolojik olarak her yedi yılda bir
yepyeni bir insan olduğumuz söylenir.
Nasıl mı?
Bu konuyu biraz daha ayrıntılandıracağım,
o yüzden bir parantez açıyorum,
sonra belgesele tekrar geri dönücem.
Vücudumuzda 37 trilyon
civarında hücre var
ve ben daha bu cümleyi söylerken,
5 milyon civarında hücrem öldü.
Beni dinlerken
ya da ekranların başında izlerken,
sizlerin de başına aynı şey geldi.
Ama endişelenmeyin,
çünkü bu ay 450 milyar civarında
yeni hücremiz olacak.
Samanyolu galaksisindeki yıldızlardan
daha fazla sayıda.
Ve yedi yıl içinde vücudumuzdaki
bütün hücreler yenilenmiş olacak.
Neredeyse tamamı.
Ve böylece biz biyolojik olarak
yepyeni bir insan olacağız.
Burada özellikle
neredeyse tamamı diyorum,
çünkü bunun çok önemli bir istisnası var,
beyin hücrelerimiz.
Onlar yenilenmiyor.
Evet, doğru duydunuz.
Onlar değişmiyor.
Peki ya onların içindeki
fikirlerimiz, düşüncelerimiz?
Belki vücudumuzdaki
hücrelerin değişiminin
farkında bile değiliz.
Tamamen bizim kontrolümüz dışında
gerçekleşiyor ama,
değişemeyen tek hücre grubu olan
beyin hücrelerimizin içindeki
fikirleri, düşünceleri değiştirebilmek,
onları dönüştürebilmek sizlerin elinde.
Diyerek parantezi kapatıp,
tekrar belgesele geri dönüyorum.
Ünlü sinema eleştirmeni Roger Eburt,
'Up' serisi adlı bu belgesel dizisini,
tüm zamanların en iyi 10 filmi
ya da bir başka deyişle,
10 hikayesi arasında sayar.
Ve hayatın gizemli merkezine
nüfus ettiğini söyler,
çünkü klasik filmlerden,
kurmaca hikayelerden
çok daha gerçektir, hakikidir.
İnsan’ın dönüşümünü
ve bu dönüşümdeki bilinmezliği
hepsinden daha iyi anlatır.
Ama insanların anlattığı ya da
uydurduğu hikayelerdeki karakterlerde de
sürekli bir dönüşüm vardır.
Zaten dönüşüm olmazsa
hikaye dediğimiz şey olmaz ki.
Ve ilginçtir bu dönüşüm
çoğu zamanda birbirine benzer.
Hatta efsaneler, mitler üzerine
araştırmalar yapan Joseph Campbell ,
"1000 yüzlü kahraman" adlı eserini
bu benzerliklerden yola çıkarak yazmıştır.
Kadim uygarlıkların oluşturduğu efsaneler,
birbirinden uzak kültürlerin anlattığı
masallar hep birbirine benzer.
Bu hikayelerde değişim adeta
bir saat gibi işler.
Kahraman tüm bu anlatılarda,
içsel yada dışsal bir yolculuğa çıkar,
maceralara atılır.
Sonra olgunlaşarak,
yani değişerek, dönüşerek
tekrar evine geri döner.
Başlangıçta gizemli bir çağır alır,
maceraya çağrı.
Daha sonra yardıma ihtiyacı
olduğunu farkeder,
o yüzden hemen destek gelir.
Muhtemel böyle bir beyaz sakallı dededen,
bir bilge kişilikten.
Sonra yuvasından,
alıştığı o konfor alanından
ayrılmak zorunda kalır,
yola çıkar.
Böylece maceramız başlamıştır,
bu özel dünyadaki macera.
Orada engellerle karşılaşılır,
çeşitli denemelerle,
bu engeller aşılmaya çalışılır.
Sonra engellerin en büyüğüne,
sınavların en zoruna yaklaşılır.
Ben diyim TEOG,
Siz deyin YGS.
Çok zorlu bir sınav.
Kahramanın karşılaştığı zorluk
o denli büyüktür ki,
hayatının en sıkıntılı,
en kötü anlarını yaşamaya başlar.
Ve o kriz anında adeta
ölümün kıyısına kadar gelir.
Tıpkı saatin gösterdiği yön gibi,
dibe vurmuştur artık.
Ama bütün bu zorluklara rağmen
hâlâ yıkılmayıp ayakta
kalmayı başaran kişi,
ödülüne mutlaka kavuşur,
aradığı hazineye ulaşır.
Çünkü dünyanın dönmesinden dolayı
mecburen oluşan gecenin
en karanlık anından hemen sonra gün doğar,
güneşin ışığına,
hazinesine kavuşuruz tekrar.
Sonuçta maceraların yaşandığı
bu özel dünyada artık
tüm zorluklar aşılmıştır.
Kahraman kendi sıradan dünyasına
dönüş yolculuğuna başlar.
Ama o artık değişmiştir.
Aradan yedi yıl geçmişmidir bilemiyorum,
ama o mutlaka değişmiştir.
Ve yeni bir hayata hazırdır artık.
Hikayede ucu açık bırakılan konular
çözüme kavuşur,
sorulan sorular cevaplandırılır
ve biz nihayet hikayenin sonuna ulaşırız
ya da yeni bir başlangıca.
Tıpkı bir saat gibi, değişim hiç bitmiyor.
Akreple yelkovanın dönüşümü
zamanı akıtıyor.
Zaman aktıkça onun içindeki
kişisel hikayelerimizi yaşayan bizler,
adım adım değişiyoruz.
Evet belki biz canavarlarla
mücadele etmiyoruz,
ama çok önemli problemlerle
karşılaşıyoruz.
Tıpkı Neil gibi,
tıpkı Frodo gibi.
Onlar gibi problemlerle yüzleşiyoruz.
Çünkü dönüşüm karar vermekle,
seçimlerle başlar.
Ve azimle,
çalışmayla,
mücadeleyle devam eder.
Eğer hayat boyunca aradığınız
bir hazine varsa,
bunun elbette bir bedeli vardır.
“Girmekten korktuğun mağara
aradığın hazineyi saklıyor.”
diyor Campbell.
Aradığınız hazineyi bulmak için,
O mağaraya girmekten,
değişmekten,
dönüşmekten korkmayın.
Evet, bugün benim kendi kişisel hikayeme
ekleyebileceğim çok güzel anlar
yaşadım burada sizlerle birlikte.
O yüzden müsadenizle ben
bu anı da kaydetmek istiyorum.
Hatta durmayın sizde kaydedin,
sonuçta bu anı birlikte yaşadık.
Kişisel hikayelerimiz, benim deyimimle
kişisel belgesellerimiz kesişti bugün.
Vaktim var gibi gözüküyor.
Size son bir şey daha,
son bir tavsiyede daha bulunmak istiyorum.
Siz de kişisel belgeselciliğe başlayın.
Daha önce kaydettiğiniz görüntüler varsa,
fotoğraflar varsa,
onları bir toparlayın.
Onlara bakarak geçmişe doğru
bir yolculuk yapmaya çalışın.
Mesela bundan yedi yıl önce
çekilmiş fotoğrafınızı bulun.
O gün nasıl hayalleriniz vardı?
Kişisel hikayenizin hangi evresindeydiniz?
Hatırlayabiliyor musunuz?
Ne kadar da değiştiniz.
Sonra yine bulabiliyorsanız,
Yedi yaşında çekilmiş
bir fotoğrafınızı bulun.
O çocuğun neye dönüşmesini istediğinizi
kendinize bir sorun.
Neye dönüşsün?
Ve kendi hayatında,
hepimizin içinde yaşadığı
bu dünyada neleri değiştirsin?
O fotoğrafa tekrar bakın.
Biraz daha yakına doğru giderseniz,
sizin kulağınıza bir şeyler
fısıldadığını duyabilirsiniz.
Kulak kabartın. Dinleyin.
Ne diyor?
Anı yakala.
Hayatını sıradışı bir hale getir.
Korkma.
Kaçınma.
Çünkü değişiyorsun
ve dünyayı değiştiriyorsun.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkışlar)